They're here aren't they.
Mr. Mulder they've been here for a long, long time.
*eery music*
Come on I'll give you guys a ride home.
Octavia, I'm going to check my self out.
You'd like a day pass?
Maybe check out Las Vegas. You could do some serious damage someplace like that.
I'm not going to Las Vegas. I'm not going anywhere, not without Mrs. Kiveat.
*speaking Chinese*
So what do we... what do we do?
What? No, no, no, I wrote all the networks. Fox was the only one that had any interest in it.
I don't know why. Federal Marshals business isn't in here it's out there trying to catch those two convicts.
No ma'am. Once I heard y'all was interested I figured we best leave it to the experts.
It used to be basketball but now the Bulls suck so... I think maybe baseball.